[Música]
en esta edición de las noticias de
France 24 la tormenta invernal heliot
comenzó a debilitarse sin embargo miles
de personas siguen en alerta por las
intensas Nevadas y Las bajas
temperaturas unos 260 mil usuarios
estuvieron a oscuras durante las
festividades de navidad al menos 30
personas han perdido la vida
Armenia ha calificado como crisis
humanitaria el cierre por parte de
activistas de azerbaiyán del único
corredor que une la región de nagorno
caravag con el mundo exterior que ha
provocado escasez de alimentos y
medicinas miles de personas piden la
apertura de esta ruta en la ciudad de
estepan aquel
y vamos a ir hasta Egipto en donde una
confitería de un siglo de antigüedad
mantiene viva la tradición de los dulces
de miel y de frutos secos reconocidos en
el mundo entero famosos para conmemorar
la Navidad Católica y también el
cumpleaños del profeta Mahoma
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos en donde la tormenta helios ya ha
comenzado a debilitarse sin embargo
miles de personas siguen sufriendo las
consecuencias de las intensas Nevadas y
Las bajas temperaturas algunos tuvieron
que pasar las fiestas de navidad sin
servicio de Electricidad cerca de 30
personas han perdido la vida hasta el
momento Marina sardina nos cuenta más en
el siguiente informe
la Navidad
moshélida en Estados Unidos la tormenta
Elliot deja Ya al menos 30 muertos en
todo el país por incidente relacionados
con este fenómeno climático extremo que
aceptó con fuerza Buffalo en el extremo
occidental del estado de Nueva York tras
los equipos de Socorro y la guardia
nacional permanecen desplegados para
paliar los daños y la fuerza de las
Nevadas comienza a debilitarse
trágicamente ha habido una pérdida de
vidas y las cifras siguen aumentando
hemos confirmado ya 12 muertes
relacionadas con la tormenta y por
desgracia sabemos que habrá más cifras
que a conocer tan pronto como se
confirmen
este domingo muchos amanecieron después
de las fiestas navideñas todavía sin
Electricidad más de 150.000 hogares y
negocios en todo el país sufren por los
daños a la red eléctrica y miles de
vuelos Fueron cancelados por la tormenta
invernal que según explicó un
meteorólogo a France 24 es también una
consecuencia de la crisis climática
mundial
que son totalmente
de los trópicos hasta el Polo Norte
Entonces es una reacción del planeta
para tratar de hacer el equilibrio
térmico Entonces ahora los que están
mandando es aire frío desde el Polo
Norte hasta la actitud tropicales Y es
que el calentamiento global habría
grabado las condiciones del ciclón bomba
de Elliot puesto que el aumento de la
temperatura del planeta está evaporando
más agua la atmósfera generando más
humedad y precipitaciones convertidas en
nieve en temporada de invierno
el gobierno de El Salvador ordenó cerca
de un barrio Popular en la capital del
país como parte de su estrategia contra
la violencia las pandillas y el
narcotráfico Aunque el gobierno defiende
las medidas algunas organizaciones
internacionales denuncian violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos Andrés triviño nos
cuenta más
no hay tregua navideña para las
pandillas en El Salvador el gobierno del
país centroamericano ordenó acercar un
barrio Popular en la capital San
Salvador conocido por narcotráfico
terrorismo y presencia de pandillas sin
remover un solo elemento del cerco de
soyapango más de 1000 soldados y 130
agentes de la policía extraerán a los
criminales que aún quedan en esta
comunidad famosa por el narcotráfico en
marzo de 2022 El Congreso aprobó un
régimen de excepción que ha sido
ampliado nueve veces y que le permite al
gobierno realizar medidas que apoyen la
polémica propuesta de bukele con la cual
pretende acabar con el terrorismo al fin
de su mandato según cifras oficiales el
plan ha dejado a más de 58.000
integrantes de estructuras terroristas
capturados y reportes de Cero homicidios
en el país mientras que organizaciones
internacionales denuncian que el régimen
de excepción suspende derechos
constitucionales y va en contra de los
Derechos Humanos después de reportar
muertes torturas y malos tratos pero el
gobierno defiende sus medidas
esta comunidad ha sido estigmatizada por
más de 40 años
se dedicaron a distribuir y vender droga
desde esta comunidad el régimen de
excepción está contemplado para ser
temporal sin embargo el presidente
bukele le ha dado un carácter indefinido
que parece estar lejos de su fin
y miles de personas se manifestaron en
el centro de la ciudad de estepanacaret
la ciudad más poblada de la
autoproclamada República de astash en
nagorno jarabach contra el bloqueo por
parte de azerbaiyán de la única ruca
ruta que comunica a Armenia y al mundo
exterior desde hace 14 días
Aparentemente un grupo de activistas
medioambientales hacer bayanos cortaron
el corredor de la china el cierre ha
provocado desabastecimiento de bienes y
de medicinas el gobierno armenio ha
acusado azerbaiyán de provocar una
crisis humanitaria también es
cuestionado el papel de Rusia cuyas
tropas son garantes en esa región
garantes de paz y de estabilidad
y en otros temas el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin se refirió a la
posibilidad de instalar una mesa de
negociaciones con las partes
involucradas en la guerra en Ucrania sin
embargo continúa la invasión en el este
del país las ciudades de gersón
continúan allí siendo blanco de fuertes
combates San Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
proteger los intereses nacionales y de
su gente Este es el objetivo principal
de la invasión rusa Ucrania a decir del
presidente Vladimir Putin sin embargo el
mandatario ratificó la disposición de
sentarse a la mesa de conversaciones
estamos preparados para negociar
soluciones aceptables con todas las
partes implicadas en el proceso es cosa
suya no somos nosotros los que nos
negamos a negociar son ellos no es la
primera vez que el presidente se refiere
al diálogo en lo que va de semana en
otra ocasión subrayó que todos los
conflictos terminan en la mesa de
negociaciones y que Moscú no renunciaba
a ello sin embargo condicionó a lo que
calificó de soluciones aceptables
sabemos
lo que dice con frecuencia no está
acostumbrado que alguien cuestiona lo
que él está diciendo y en este momento
yo creo que no tenemos una respuesta
Clara cuál pueden ser estos condiciones
Rusia ha perdido el terreno en Ucrania a
pesar que fue decla
Rusia declaró estos territorios como
parte de su territorio nuevamente pero
básicamente yo creo que debemos esperar
que van a aparecer mayores detalles por
ahora no está muy claro Cuáles van a ser
estas condiciones en este sentido la
guerra continúa en bahmud objetivo del
kremlin desde hace semanas Los
bombardeos Invasores no cesan
pensé que este sábado se viviría un
ambiente festivo pero de ninguna manera
ya que todos los días estamos lidiando
con el sufrimiento de las personas sabes
y eso tiene sus consecuencias
los enfrentamientos también prosiguen
allí 13 asentamientos fueron afectados
por los ataques de las fuerzas del
kremlin el conflicto cumplió este 24 de
diciembre 10 meses de acciones
ininterrumpidas sin una posibilidad
visible del cese de los ataques
en Egipto una confitería de un siglo de
antigüedad mantiene viva la tradición de
los dulces de con frutos secos que son
reconocidos en el mundo entero y que
están asociados a la celebración
religiosa de la Navidad y el cumpleaños
del profeta Mahoma pero ahora también
forman parte de otras tradiciones
cristianas veamos los dulces de frutos
secos y miel tienen raíces en el Antiguo
Egipto milenios después los árabes
difundieron en sus conquistas esas
recetas vinculadas a sus celebraciones
religiosas y así ocurrió en otros
lugares del mundo donde el turrón forma
parte de la Navidad Navidad anntar es
experto en confeccionarlas las en
semilla o turrón de sésamo la puleya de
cacahuate el lugar el de almendras o el
de avellanas Hacemos todos son los
dulces del cumpleaños del profeta es la
tercera generación de pasteleros y con
49 años tiene más de 30 de práctica por
intuición conoce los tiempos y las
texturas que debe lograr
la textura debe ser como si fuera
cristal
la historia de navila es inseparable de
la de heratía y de la de la confitería
El Nilo que fundó el abuelo de nadería
hace 100 años
la tienda se abrió en 1928 al principio
era conocida como la pastelería del rey
porque el rey fuat el padre del Rey
faruk solía comer los dulces de aquí
entre sus favoritos estaba el turrón de
almendra ungirlache como el que siglos
antes se consumía en al-ándalus y que se
elabora con miel glucosa y almendras los
árabes lo habían llevado a las costas
del Mediterráneo donde se ha hecho un
hueco hasta nuestros días en la
confitería del nido se elabora con la
misma receta desde hace un siglo y desde
que el abuelo de nader fundó la
confitería ha habido en el Obrador un
miembro de la familia de Navidad
otras tiendas compran parte de los
ingredientes porque no tienen un chef
que sepa cómo hacerlos yo lo tengo el
nieto aprendió de su padre y el padre
aprendió del suyo
cuando veo el producto final me siento
orgulloso si no estoy convencido de ello
creo que a nadie le gustará me tiene que
gustar primero a mí
la calidad de los productos
seleccionados sumados a la experiencia y
devoción al trabajo herencia de
generaciones de Navidad son la clave
para obtener un resultado a la altura de
Reyes
todo el manjar es todas las noticias
buenas noches
[Música]